they sent humans to walk on the moon
flew by every single planet in our solar
system and delivered the first residents
to the International Space Station
what else could NASA have done if it had
a bigger budget say the budget of the US
military how close would we be to
colonizing Mars would you be spending
your vacation on the moon
what about visiting other solar systems
this is what if and here's what would
happen if NASA had the US military's
budget in 1969 NASA spent over 25
billion dollars or about a hundred and
seventy billion in today's money so that
the whole world could see this but once
a small step for man became one giant
leap for mankind the budget of the
american-led Space Agency started
shrinking today NASA gets less than
twenty billion dollars annually to
explore and colonize what's out there is
that enough for humanity's ambitions not
if you plan on buying a piece of land on
the moon what if due to a printing error
in the federal budget all the money
destined for the US military went to the
space agency instead what would six
hundred billion dollars pay for here's
the International Space Station the
largest artificial satellite that's ever
orbited earth over 200 people have lived
and worked here since it launched in
1998 but it may be defunded as of 2024
and then no one's gonna set foot on it
with another hundred billion dollars
NASA could afford to keep doing the
research on the ISS for at least another
20 years
a military size budget would cover that
not only would it allow the space
station to remain up and running but it
would also allow them to send more
astronauts and there'd still be enough
money left over for NASA's biggest
ongoing projects developing the Space
Launch System that would carry us to the
moon and deep space not a problem
and then there's Mars together with
SpaceX NASA could restore the uncrewed
red dragon mission that would mark the
beginning of Mars colonization sending
the first humans to Mars would cost NASA
around four hundred and fifty billion
dollars
with six hundred billion dollars of
annual funding a crewed mission to the
red planet would become NASA's next
Apollo very quickly we build a human
colony on the moon turning it into a
base for our trips into deep space it
would also serve as a blueprint for Mars
colonization we'd move up the launch
date on the Europa clipper a mission to
Jupiter smallest moon in search of signs
of alien life in the oceans of liquid
water beneath it's icy shell maybe
Europa would become our next destination
for the crewed missions
just imagine regular commercial
spaceflight uncrewed missions to other
solar systems increasing biological and
physiological studies to figure out how
humans could survive away from Earth
wouldn't that be awesome what else do
you think we could achieve with a
military budget
[Music]
you